[Musik]
[Applaus]
mal ehrlich welche bilder gehen dir
durch den kopf wenn du an detroit text
dicke amerikanische straßenkreuzer wohl
nur kurz und danach brach liegende
vertreten und industriegebiete trostlose
straßenbilder und ganze viertel voller
zugenagelte verlassene und verfallene
häuser
dabei war detroit die
bevölkerungsreichste stadt des
bundesstaates michigan mal die automobil
hauptstadt amerikas ja gar der ganzen
welt riesige konzerne wie ford und
general motors hatten hier ihre haupt
niederlassungen und produktionsstätten
aber das ist lange her im jahr 1950
lebten hier fast zwei millionen menschen
zu jenem zeitpunkt war der schritt zu
einem der attraktivsten orte zu
abertausenden arbeitern aus den ganzen
usa geworden
hier war für sie die verwirklichung des
american dream so greifbar wie nirgendwo
sonst
wir sprechen von einer stadt die einst
die viertgrößte stadt der usa war direkt
hinter new york los angeles und chicago
doch dann ging etwas schief und ab den
1950 er jahren begann alles wie ein
kartenhaus einzustürzen
viele unternehmen begann zu entlassen
oder gar zu schließen es kam zu
kürzungen der produktionsketten und als
erste gingen viele zulieferbetriebe im
automobilsektor pleite es begann sich
eine unaufhaltsame absatz spirale zu
drehen
1960 hatte den schritt bereits fast
200.000 einwohner verloren ja nur zehn
jahren 200.000 menschen weniger seitdem
schrumpft die stadt jahrzehnt für
jahrzehnt ist auf den heutigen stand von
670.000 einwohnern dieses diagramm zeigt
uns auf drastische weise wiederholt dazu
verdammt scheint eine geisterstadt zu
werden dabei bestand das problem nicht
nur darin dass so viele menschen und
wegzogen sondern auch dass die einkommen
der verbliebenen immer weiter sanken
zurück blieb nur ein extrem armes und
sehr unsicheres umfeld natürlich suchen
im fall einer solchen katastrophe viele
nach erklärungen
und hier wird es interessant denen der
springende punkt ist dass sich in der
wissenschaft als erklärung dieses
phänomens zwei grundlegende
argumentationslinien
herauskristallisiert haben die
vollkommen entgegengesetzt sind die
einen sehen im kapitalismus den
hauptschuldigen und die anderen
behaupten das genaue gegenteil dass er
eine schlechte sozialpolitik zu dieser
schrecklichen situation geführt hast
worauf sich beide seiten einigen können
ist die tatsache dass detroit das
paradebeispiel dafür ist dass der
american dream keine gesetzmäßigkeit
darstellt sondern mein smart aufhaltsame
in sein gegenteil eine american
nightmare abdriften kann
was aber nun ist die ursache für den
niedergang detroits war als der böse
kapitalismus wie steht es heute um diese
stadt und welche lektionen können unsere
politiker aus ihrem schicksal lernen
keine angst all das wirst du heute in
diesem video erfahren also los geht's
[Musik]
das dröhnen der motoren
sieh dir diese bilder
[Musik]
überall dort wo jetzt freie flächen sind
standen einst häuser in den letzten
jahren hat der stadtrat von detroit
versucht jedes verlassene haus
abzureißen und so verhindern dass ist
von hausbesetzern und junkies
vereinnahmen sondern drogenküche
umgebaut oder auf irgendeine andere
weise als brutstätte von kriminalität
genutzt wird du musst dir vorstellen
dass all diese slums früher ganz normale
schnuppe mittelklasse wohnviertel waren
die wir sie in jeder anderen us
stattfinden können heutzutage aber sind
es orte um die jeder normale mensch
lieber einen weiten bogen macht diese
viertel sind in rahmen eines enormen
demografischen dunst entstanden
innerhalb von drei jahrzehnten zwischen
1920 und 1950 verdoppelte sich die
bevölkerung dies allein von 1920 bis 30
wenn du zehn jahren zogen 600.000 neue
menschen in die stadt du kommst du
natürlich schon denken warum da war es
plötzlich so viele menschen nach detroit
kamen ab dem 06 frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhundert begann sich in detroit eine
mächtige automobilindustrie zu
entwickeln dutzende kleine fabriken
aller ermöglichen automobilist da gab's
schossen wie pilze aus dem boden und
eines von ihnen war das von henry ford
der dort 1899 die idee zurück automobile
company gründete anfangs lief das
geschäft nicht so gut wie erwartet fort
musste nach nur zwei jahren schließen
nachdem er nur 20 autos verkauft und den
gegenwert von mehr als 2 erhält
millionen dollar an heutige geld in den
wind geschossen hatte auch sein zweiter
versuch scheiterte aber dort gab nicht
auf 903 gründete er mit frischen geld
die ford motor company in heutigen
dollars tauchte er dazu nur noch 800.000
denn wie heißt es so schön aller guten
dinge sind drei kleiner comeback
entgegen der landläufigen meinung war
henry ford nicht der erste der die
produktion im automobilbau eingeführt
hatte nein das erste serienmäßig
hergestellte auto war der crash von
hohes mobil
richtig ist jedoch das s wort gelang
dieses system auf ein noch nie
dagewesenes effizienz und rentabilität
niveau zu heben seine
optimierungsmaßnahmen senken sowohl
kosten als auch produktionszeiten
drastisch und zwar unter jene
ausschlaggebende schwelle um aus dem
automobil- ein für jedermann
erschwinglich des produkts machen freie
fahrt für die massen
[Musik]
und dieser ford is muss so wird ein
produktionssystem genannt sollte auch
die stadt detroit für immer verändern
und ich meine damit nicht nur die
wirtschaft der stadt oder eher industrie
modell sondern ihre ganze demografischen
struktur denn alle fingen an ford zu
kopieren und ihre fabriken begann zu
wachsen und zu wachsen und damit der
bedarf nach neuen arbeitern und jetzt
ratet mal welche soziale gruppe am
stärksten in den sog dieser die kräuter
automobilfabriken gerät genau es waren
meistens afroamerikaner die aus dem zu
starten kann
und das war nicht ganz unproblematisch
denn wir sprechen hier über das frühe
zwanzigste jahrhundert in den usa
herrschte damals wie in praktisch allen
westlichen ländern ein ungetrübter
rassismus der zuzug hunderttausender
schwarzer in einer bis dahin überwiegend
weiße stadt verursachte sofort enorme
spannungen und ein riesiges misstrauen
unter den einwohnern aus diesem grund
begann weiße aus der stadt in die
peripherie zu ziehen eine neu errichtete
wohngebiete und in mitchells kernstadt
bildeten sich im laufe der jahre soziale
ghettos in die aufgrund dessen wurde
roman als immer mehr arbeiter zogen aber
jetzt fragst du dich vielleicht mag das
in aller welt haben rassismus und
wohnungsknappheit mit den niedergang
wird stolz zu tun nun viel mehr als man
auf den ersten blick vermuten würde
schaut alle dieses sozialen spannungen
wuchsen im laufe der jahre immer mehr an
und immer häufiger erleben sie sich in
form von unruhen 1967 wurde aufgrund
eines frei erfunden gerichts mehr als
2500 geschäfte der weißen bevölkerung
geplündert und mehr als irgendein
gebäude darunter viele wohnhäuser
niedergebrannt und den erdboden gleich
gemacht und jetzt kommen wir alle einen
entscheidenden moment die malst du
reagierten politik und behörden
diese herausforderung nur zu viele
experten liegt gerade hier die
eigentliche ursache eines problems das
bis heute anhält
die politiker in detroit und michigan
wollten natürlich verhindern dass sich
etwas ähnliches wie die unruhen von 1967
wiederholen du musst dir vorstellen dass
der tod damals ja noch immer reich war
die automobilindustrie punkte noch das
geld und die steuereinnahmen flossen
doch reichlich also führten die
politiker sehr radikale und ehrgeizige
sozialprogramme eine wie zum beispiel
die massenhaft einstellung von
afro-amerikanern in der öffentlichen
verwaltung ihrer bevorzugung bei aller
arten von förderung massive subventionen
und die einführung des zu hause nackt
eines umfangreichen programms zur
schaffung erschwinglichen wohnraums so
und jetzt hat jemand welches ziel dieses
geniale wohl förderprogramm hatte das
muss man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen also kern des für hausen etwa
noch mehr einkommensschwache
bevölkerungsteile in der innenstadt von
detroit anzusiedeln also in genau jenen
stadtteilen aus denen die flucht der
weißen bevölkerung in vororte und
anderer städte bereits begonnen hat
heute wurde so zu einem großen sozialen
versuchslabor und wie du dir vorstellen
kannst endete dieses soziale experiment
in der katastrophe
im laufe der jahre führte genau diese
art von politik dazu dass viele
einwohner vollkommen abhängig von der
alimentierung durch die stadt wurden
ihre integration in die arbeitswelt
wurde immer schwieriger denn sie hatten
keine anreize sich zu qualifizieren und
am wettbewerbsorientierten arbeitsleben
teilzunehmen es handelt es sich um die
schlimmste einseitigsten art von
sozialpolitik den man sich vorstellen
kann es wurde auf teufel komm raus und
völlig kopflos alimentiert und
subventioniert masse statt klasse
die stadt nichts um die soziale
ausgrenzung und rassismus von beiden
seiten einzudämmen die flucht der weißen
aus verwaltung unternehmen und
stadtvierteln wo sie nicht gestoppt die
gewalt nicht bekämpft und die gründung
neuer unternehmen nicht angeregt die
politiker glaubten
dann könnten alle probleme einfach
nachdem dies kann im prinzip mit einem
haufen kohle lösen machten damit aber
alles nur noch schlimmer
und so meine lieben zuschauer verblasste
der einstige automobil hauptstadt nach
und nach aber wachte einen augenblick
denn das alles war erst der anfang
zu jenem zeitpunkt als detroit michigan
wenigstens noch über die steuereinnahmen
verfügten um ihre sozialen experimente
zu finanzieren und dann die alten
automobilfabriken des frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts nach und nach zu schließen
ihre produktionsanlagen waren
mittlerweile veraltet die zunehmende
automatisierung macht enorme
investitionen notwendig und es lohnte
sich mehr woanders ganz neue vertreten
zu bauen als die alten zu modernisieren
also begannen die großen
automobilkonzerne ihren fabriken
zunächst an den stadträndern von der
schweiz zu bauen
doch schon nach kurzer zeit stellten sie
fest dass auch dort kein gutes
produktionsumfeld herrscht
der hohe grad an automatisierung
verlangte nach immer mehr ingenieuren
und qualifizierten arbeitern und diese
wollten wieder in detroit noch in seinen
vororten leben
sie wurden von der wachsenden gewalt und
den zahlreichen sozialen konflikten in
der stadt abgeschreckt genauso wie von
der in detroit in michigan
anzutreffenden höheren steuer und
abgabenbelastung die zur finanzierung
der ganzen teuren sozialprogramme
notwendig geworden war die neuen
modernen fabriken wurden also ganz
woanders gebaut in anderen städten und
anderen bundesstaaten der kreislauf aus
verarmung und entvölkerung der stadt
detroit in also in die nächste runde
jetzt kannst du sie sich vorstellen
welche katastrophe als nächstes auf die
stadt zukommen die steuereinnahmen
brachen ein
denn unternehmen und menschen mit hohem
einkommen waren ja fortgezogen und all
jene die sich dies nicht leisten konnten
die ganze welt wenn die waren da
geblieben
das machte die finanzielle situation der
stadt zu einer tickenden zeitpunkt wie
im treibsand versinkt
die panisch mit den beinen strampeln
gaben die wechsel mit bürgermeister von
detroit jedoch weiterhin riesige summe
aus im glauben damit doch noch irgendwie
die kurve kriegen von säuren sozialhilfe
programmen bis hin zu gigantischen
öffentlichen bau programmen da sie
mittlerweile aber nicht mehr über die
steuermittel verfügten finanzierten sich
das alles natürlich auch pumpen und so
kam es wie es kommen musste im jahr 2013
wartet scheut so hoch verschuldet dass
es selbst seine alten schulden aus neuen
schulden nicht mehr bedienen konnte die
stadt pleite zahlungsunfähig so weit so
schlecht aber lasst uns an dieser stelle
mal einen schnitt machen denn genau hier
am tiefsten punkt ihrer geschichte
beginnt für detroit eine ganz neue ära
ein neuanfang für detroit ist eher
möglich versuchte ich mal für einen
moment in die lade der stadtverwaltung
von sie zurollt hineinzuversetzen soll
es entgegen
schon vor ihrer zahlungsunfähigkeit im
jahr 2013 war die stadt zug klar dass
sie nicht einmal mehr das geld hatte um
die grundversorgung der bürger
sicherzustellen keine müllabfuhr kein
wasser ganz zu schweigen von der wartung
oder instandsetzung von abwasserkanälen
und natürlich auch keine sicherheit im
laufe der jahre hatte die stadt eine
riesige schuldenlast von 14 milliarden
dollar angehäuft und allein im jahr 2013
erreichen des haushaltsdefizits 327
millionen dollar und überleg mal detroit
hatte damals nur noch 600 90.000
einwohnern das heißt die kommunalen
schulden beliefen sich auf mehr als
20.000 dollar pro kopf vom baby bis zum
rentner für eine schützende stadt ist
das sehr viel geld zu vergleichen
spricht sonst im schnitt der gesamten
restlichen verschuldung pro kopf in
einem land mit recht hoher schuldenlast
wie zb spanien gesprächen hier von allen
staatsschulden von der kommunalen
regionalen landes- und bundesebene
zusammengenommen also so viele schulden
eines krisenstabs lasteten auf den
bürgern nur einer stadt detroit
[Musik]
aber natürlich verfügt eine einzelne
stadtverwaltung nicht über die einnahmen
quellen eines ganzen staates so hohe
schulden bedienen zu können diese
situation veranlasste die stadt dazu
eine reihe schwere einschnitte
durchzusetzen
zum beispiel mussten den öffentlichen
dienst hätten erhebliche
gehaltskürzungen und erzwungenen
unbezahlten urlaub hinnehmen schließlich
verlor die troll jedoch auch die hoheit
über seine stadtkasse die
us-bundesregierung übernahmen die
führung der stadtfinanzen und führte
drastische maßnahmen zu ihrer
umstrukturierung durch die gute
nachricht für die schuld war jedoch dass
dieser ganze prozess nicht lange
gedauert
[Musik]
nach dem eingreifen der bundesregierung
und vereinbarungen zur streichung und
umstrukturierung von mehr als sieben
milliarden dollar schulden
gelernt ist der stadt den bankrott zu
entkommen nebenbei bemerkt bedeutet dies
natürlich im grunde genommen dass viele
gläubiger einen guten teil ihres geldes
verloren haben aber vorsichtig sprechen
jetzt nur über die rege finanzhaie
sondern vor allem über pensionsfonds
[Musik]
denn am ende bekommen solche
schuldenschnitte sehr viele kleine leute
zu spüren deswegen weniger altersrente
bekommen und die damit 80 im supermarkt
tüten packen müssen um über die runden
zu kommen
all diese verschwenderischen
ausgabenprogramme der stadt detroit
wurden letzten endes von diesen leuten
erarbeitet und bezahlt deswegen muss
detroit jetzt einen strikten plan zur
ausgabenkontrolle befolgen es muss jahr
für jahr überschüsse vorweisen
um die verbleibenden schulden weiter
abbauen und gleichzeitig die
sicherstellung des öffentlichen
dienstleistungsangebots schrittweise
wieder herzustellen und erinnerst du
dich noch an die leere grundstücke die
wir zu beginn dieses videos gezeigt
haben wie gesagt standen dort vorher
verfallene häuser die als brutstätten
der kriminalität bekannt waren
der stadtrat hatte aber noch nicht
einmal das geld um sie abzureißen und
all das änderte sich nach der
zahlungsunfähigkeit den schuldenschnitt
und den austerität maßnahmen und siehe
da tatsächlich erlebte tritt
mittlerweile allen widrigkeiten zum
trotz einen boom privater investitionen
menschen die angst angst hatten in der
stadt zu investieren lieferten sich nun
ein wettrennen um die lukrativsten
investitionsgelegenheiten zu ergattern
wenn sie jetzt nach detroit gel ist es
eine andere stadt als vor fünf jahren
sie hat ein anderes image muss ist eine
lebendige stadt
viele dieser investitionen kommen vor
allem aus den großen metropolen new york
und los angeles
und auch heute kann man
sanierungsprojekte von risiken gebäuden
gestanden
die einst den herzen der stadt
aufgegeben worden
[Musik]
und nicht nur das auch die industrie
selbst beginnt wieder suggeriert fiat
chrysler plant investitionen in michigan
mit 6.500 arbeitsplätze
der italienisch amerikanische
autohersteller sagte er plane in den
nächsten drei jahren 4,5 milliarden
dollar auszugeben um mehrere werke in
detroit auf den neuesten stand zu
bringen und ein motorenwerk für die
herstellung von chips umzurüsten
ein vorhaben das nach angaben des
unternehmens etwa 6.500 neue
arbeitsplätze schaffen würde und es
kommt noch mehr
im jahr 2018 kaufte die ford motor
company die ehemalige michigan schloss
station ein großes verlassenes gebäude
das immer wieder als symbol des
niedergangs angeführt wurde ford
investiert 740 millionen dollar
und hier sei die entwicklungshilfe
autonom fahrende fahrzeuge anzusiedeln
die speerspitze der automobilen zukunft
also ford gibt detroit also eine zweite
große chance
darüber hinaus ist aus sozialer sicht
eines der programme dass die meisten
hoffnungen weckte user weise eine
ehrgeizige eingliederungs presley und
alles könnte man glauben wir sprechen
hier über sehr sehr viele menschen denn
diese stadt nicht nur viele jahrzehnte
lang unter unglaublicher hohen
kriminalitätsraten nein sie ist noch
immer einer der gefährlichsten ort in
den usa und diese sind insgesamt wie wir
alle wissen nicht gerade für ein hohes
maß an sicherheit bekannt ich glaube wir
können uns hier im beschaulichen europa
gar nicht vorstellen
wovon dabei die rede ist detroit ist
sozusagen eine stadt voller
schwerverbrecher ganze 15 prozent der
einwohner wurden bereits wegen einer
oder mehreren schweren straftaten
verurteilt das ist jeder sechste in der
stadt
auch hier inklusive babys und rentner
und die dunkelziffer liegt natürlich
noch viel viel höher
denn die unterfinanzierte polizei und
die justiz waren sehr lange zeit gar
nicht in der lage die mehrzahl der
verbrecher zu verfolgen erinnert ihr
euch noch an den film robocop in denen
die polizeigewalt an ein
privatunternehmen ausgesucht wurde das
dann versuchte mit polizei robotern
beziehungsweise androiden die ausufernde
gewalt einzudämmen nun dieser film
spielte nicht da zufällig in detroit der
opel war zwar nur science fiction aber
die im film dargestellten dystopischen
zustände waren auch imperialen detroit
bittere wirklichkeit und auch wenn du
ein kleiner teil der verbrechen
überhaupt verurteilt wird entlassen die
strafvollzugsbehörden von michigan jedes
jahr etwa 9000 häftlinge von denen 25
prozent nachweisen konnte also detroit
gehen nach einer langen haftstrafe
wieder in die gesellschaft integriert zu
werden ist in jedem land schwierig aber
in den usa ganz besonders
etwa 60 der in michigan auf bewährung
entlassen haben keinen job und viele
sind daher versucht in irgendeiner art
von kriminalität zurückzukehren
ein weiteres problem durch die darin
dass viele kein vermieter finden
überhaupt bereit wäre an ehemalige
sträflinge zu vermieten deshalb hat der
stadtrat von metroid einer verordnung
erlassen welche die grossen er hat halt
nicht daran hindert die vermietung eines
hauses an eine person aufgrund ihrer
vorstrafen auszuschließen
darüber hinaus wurden programme zur
förderung der wiedereingliederung
ehemaliger häftlinge in die arbeitswelt
aufgelegt übrigens ist dies ein thema
über das wir noch viel ausführlicher in
einem zukünftigen video sprechen müssen
denn detroit herzen noch einen sehr
langen weg vor sich
[Musik]
die im zuge der bekämpfung des corona
virus ausgelöste wirtschaftskrise droht
alle fortschritte zu gefährden während
das corona virus in deutschland
grassiert vergrößert die pandemie die
armut und die rassen unterschiede in der
stadt
diese große wirtschaftskrise gefährdet
in der tat viele der investitionen auf
welche detroit bereits fest vertraut
hatte da investitionen in detroit
weitaus mehr risiken bergen als in
anderen teilen der vereinigten staaten
doch was lehrt uns diese geschichte des
goldenen zeitalters ist anschließend
niedergangs und der wiedergeburt einer
der wichtigsten industrie- stelle des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts eines symbols
der wirtschaftskraft amerikas des
american dream mit häuschen und auto nun
diese geschichte führt uns anschaulich
vor augen dass in der politik der weg in
die hölle oft mit guten absichten
gepflastert ist gute absichten und viel
geld reichen eben nicht aus um erfolg zu
haben wichtiger sind analytischer
rationaler sachverstand eine
realistische wahrnehmung oder mut die
wahrheit auszusprechen und danach zu
handeln so und jetzt bist du dran
glaubst du dass detroit in ein paar
jahrzehnten die neue automobil
hauptstadt amerikas und er könnte oder
wird tesla sowieso die alten automaten
begraben was können wir daraus lernen
dass eine der größten städte amerikas
durch eine fehlgeleitete zuwanderungs
und sozialpolitik zur hölle auf erden
wurde schreibt uns alles was ihr
einfällt als kommentar unter dieses
video
denn wie immer sind diese schon
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe dass wir
dieses video gefallen vielleicht auch
etwas gebracht hat falls ja gibt uns
einen daumen hoch und unterstütze uns in
denen du bist mit deinen freunden heißt
und vergesst bitte nicht dass wir jede
woche neue videos hochladen
also unsere grad und blick auf das
kleine symbol um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden was gut und ist
zum nächsten mal